[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up Roth hello Walter we're back
again yes and I'm excited for this
discussion okay will you open up was yes
let's do that Heavenly Father as we are
going to discuss the central issue of
the plan of salvation I pray that you
will be with us with your spirit what
this is such an important topic and I
pray that you will enlighten our minds
that you may become more and we may
become less in Jesus name Amen
yes sir last time we got to the
Salvation issue of the atonement and can
you briefly give us an introduction or a
recap of what we've been doing in the in
the past two lectures yes we were
discussing Babylon and the doctrine of
the serpent and our introductory text
was Genesis chapter 3 verse 1 where the
serpent said unto the woman has God said
and then we looked at the three lies or
distortions that the devil brought into
the world and the first one as you will
remember was about the immortality will
surely not die and then we looked at the
second one ye shall be as gods and the
third one was you will be able to
distinguish between good and evil and
then we we went through the
documentation and we saw that wrong
preachers as doctrine all three of the
serpent statements all three of them so
in other words it's not what God said
it's what the serpent said that is
central but this is one issue that is
not exactly emphasized here with
very very important and that was the
statement where after the fall of man
the promise was given of the Messiah
that would come remember it said and I
will put enmity between thee and the
woman and between thy seed and her seed
and it shall bruise thy head and thou
shalt bruise his heel this was this
great messianic promise that the Messiah
would come and would crush the Serpent's
head remember we discussed how in the
Douay Rheims Bible the Roman Catholic
Church via the Jesuits changed it so
that it became feminine and they say it
is a reference to Mary but it could just
as well be a reference to the church yes
so the church will actually achieve this
because everything they say is based on
what the church says and not on what God
says so this enmity between thee and the
woman and the seed of the Serpent and
the seed of Christ's bride would
continue until the close of probation so
this would be a theme that runs through
the entire history and this war will
continue until the second coming and
also in that lecture we had this slide
which said did God really say that there
was only one way by which atonement
could be secured and you remember in
Genesis chapter 4 verse 4 we read an
Abel he also brought of the firstlings
of his flock and of the fat thereof and
the Lord had respect unto Abel and unto
his offering but unto Cain and to his
offering and not respect and came was
very wroth in his car
now here are two ways of atonement that
are described here the one was the way
of Abel which was to bring the offering
of the lamb which foreshadowed the
coming of Christ and the other offering
was the offerings of the works of his
own hands
and the fact that Cain was very wroth
when he's offering wasn't accepted that
is part of human nature you want to be
able to do this yourself why should you
be totally dependent yes and this is
such an important issue so there was a
question also on the offering that Cain
brought he was a not a livestock farmer
so why was he's offering not acceptable
well God had prescribed the way in which
this had to take place and it wasn't
something that was introduced at the
time of Cain and Abel it was introduced
at the time of the fall of Adam and Eve
because they had to sacrifice a lamb or
a sheep they had to sacrifice it because
that was the typology and just like the
Jews had to bring a lamb and sacrifice
it and then the priest took over so Adam
and Eve had to slaughter that creature
that animal and the blood that flowed
was a type of the blood of Christ that
would flow in their behalf so what about
the the portion in the Bible that says
God made the garments for Adam and Eve
correct so what was Adam and Eve's
contribution they had to bring the
offering they had to kill the offering
and God made the garments he provided a
type of the robe of righteousness that
they
he who would present now some people
think that God actually made the first
sacrifice there Adam and Eve had to
sacrifice it because if you look further
on as it was prescribed to the Jews if
you were a sinner and you brought a
sacrificial animal you were the one that
had to cut the throat you are the one
that had to initiate the action because
you were responsible for the death of
the land so here we see that Cain's
offering was not accepted now if it was
prescribed and you had to bring a lamb
then he should have bothered with his
vegetables for the lamb but probably you
know they were farmers they had all of
these things so he could have brought
the lamb he wasn't only concentrating on
one issue in those days they didn't have
monoculture they had all kinds of foods
that they were working with and the
animals were part and parcel of farm
existence and life and they were used
for for work so Abel brought the
offering that was acceptable Cain
brought the offering that was not
acceptable and this conflict has been
raging since the beginning of time and
the anti-typical Cain's of today are
still very Roth and their countenance
has fallen they will not accept that you
can be saved by the blood of the lamb
alone that's why this atonement issue is
so important now when we looked at the
previous one and we looked at the three
issues that the serpent mentioned before
Adam and Eve fell that you will surely
not die that you shall be like God
and that you will be able in your own
power to determine between right and
wrong you don't need God for that
then we saw in our discussion that that
is exactly what the Roman Church teaches
the three lives of Eden now in terms of
the atonement which one of the two
methods to be consistent now do you
think that they accept as their to
accept Cain's method Cain's method in
fact they call Abel's method and an
asthma and an F me you accursed if you
follow Abel's method so we need to go
into a little bit of detail concerning
this issue because this is the heart of
the gospel and then when you put the
package together you will see that the
one is biblical and is the way that God
prescribed and the other one is the way
of Cain and is the exact opposite of
what God prescribed the devil is the
master of reversal he turns everything
upside down
so let's and if you're if you are the
part of the site and you can realize
that you're part of the side that is
believing Cain's
and all the three lies of the devil then
you know you're part of Babylon yes and
even if you have aspects of it then
you're partly babylonian but once you
accept the authority of the one that is
completely Babylonian and then you
become part of Babylon so let's have a
look at the atonement yes as I chapter
53 verse 12 therefore will I divide him
a portion with the Great and he shall
divide the spoil with the strong because
he has poured out his soul and to
death and he was numbered with the
transgressors and he bare the sin of
many and made intercession for the
transgressors and the scripture was
fulfilled which says and he was numbered
with the transgressors what a beautiful
verse in Isaiah pointing to Jesus Christ
who bore the sins of many and made
intercession for the transgressors this
is the plan of salvation in Romans 3
verse 25 we read whom God has set forth
to be a propitiation a mercy seat as it
were a healer sterian through faith in
his blood to declare his righteousness
for the remission of sins that are past
through the forbearance of God to
declare I say at this time his
righteousness that he might be just and
the justifier of him which believers in
Jesus where is boasting then it is
excluded by what law of works no but by
the law of faith so the Bible clearly
teaches that we are saved by faith
through the blood of the Lamb we have no
righteousness of our own righteousness
is imputed and imparted through Jesus
Christ this is the biblical teaching and
we are saved through his blood in other
words Jesus died for me because the life
is in the blood rise rom denies that rom
says Jesus never died for you he died
but I didn't die for you he died as an
act of perfect obedience and because of
his perfect obedience and righteousness
God forgives you but he didn't do it for
you so in Catholic theology you have to
work off your sins you have to do the
penance you have to pay the
price now when your sins are forgiven
then you still haven't paid the price
for those sins so in Catholic theology
when you go to heaven you can't go to
heaven
because you haven't paid the price for
your sins yet so you must go to
purgatory and there you pay the price
for the sins and depending on how much
your sins was that depends on your time
in purgatory correct
that's Catholic theology in biblical
theology Jesus Christ paid the price
according to Isaiah he paid the price
and it is through his blood that I am
saved and his righteousness is imputed
and imparted to me this is the biblical
position so let's have a look at the
Lutheran confession and this states the
gospel I ever is that doctrine which
teaches what a man should believe in
order to obtain forgiveness of sins from
God since man has failed to keep the law
of God and has transgressed it he's
corrupted nature's thoughts words and
deeds war against the law and he's
therefore subject to the wrath of God
all have sinned and fall short of the
glory of God the wages of sin is death
death and deeds war against the law and
he is therefore subject to the wrath of
God to death to temporal miseries and to
the punishment of hellfire the content
of the gospel is this that the son of
God Christ our Lord Himself assumed and
bought the curse of the law which is
deadly and expiated and paid for all of
our sins that through him alone we
re-enter the good graces of God obtain
forgiveness of sins through faith or
freed from death and all the punishment
of sin and are saved eternally so
there's no purgatory here because
there's no purgatory and the Bible it is
a Catholic invention
okay X in fact it's a Greek philosophy
now the wrath of God this comes from
manuscript releases this is an Adventist
source god so loved the world that He
gave His only begotten Son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life John
3:16 these words show us why God's wrath
descended on his only begotten Son while
the innocent suffered for the guilty why
the just bore the punishment wholly due
to the unjust Jesus came to bear the
penalty of man's transgressions to
uphold and vindicate the immutability of
the law of God and the rectitude of his
government he came to make an end of sin
and to bring in everlasting
righteousness
this is totally biblical so why did
Jesus have to die well because the law
of God could not be taken away because
the Bible says where there is no law
there's no transgression if there's no
transgression then there is no penalty
so the fact that he died meant that the
law could not have been taken away and
all the reformers recognized this and
they make it quite plain that the fact
that Jesus died means that the law
stands Wesley said it what Luther said
it fella said it
why does modern Protestantism say that
the death of Christ does away with the
law if he could have taken the law away
then he would not have had to die you
could have just stated exactly so modern
Protestantism is also marching in the
paths of Babylon because if you take the
law away you take away the government of
God if you've taken away the government
of God what government have you put in
its place the government of the
government of man which are they keeping
are they keeping the Sunday will be
keeping the Saturday so which law
they're keeping they're keeping them
the purpose of Babylon so that's a
Babylonian teaching it's a Babylonian
teaching and Sun so to put it bluntly
you are part of Babylon if you adhere to
these teachings there's a little there's
a little a rider in the Bible which says
if you know and you do it not then it be
for your sin but there's another verse
which says the time of ignorance God
winked said so nobody is responsible
until they are confronted with truth
convicted of truth and reject the truth
but the world is moving in the direction
of Babylonian teaching including the
Protestants now Catholics deny that God
poured out his wrath on the son and some
of their theologians or at least those
from the Jesus Institute say well if
this is the case then you should love
the son but take the father I've heard
that have you heard that statement
what's kind of father would do that they
were there to East but you see they
don't understand the deity because Jesus
says I am the father or one mmm-hmm so
the entire godhood was involved why
wasn't Jesus that had to die because in
Adam all have sinned I inherited Adam's
fallen nature in who was Adam before
Adam sinned incra he was in Christ so
all of humanity in its unfallen state
was in Christ before it was in Adam
because he's the creator therefore only
God only the creator could pay this
price therefore like Martin Luther I
want to reiterate and I stand with him
the God who didn't die for me is not my
god because nobody else could die for me
because the Bible clearly says that I
may not inherit your sins and you may
not inherit my sons I must be
responsible for my own sins so only
God in whom all humanity was
cooperatively could die for my sons but
what is he require of me I once word an
interesting discussion was he us back
and he was a lawyer and he knew I was a
Christian and I was dealing with
property I was buying a property and he
was the lawyer and we started talking
and one day he said please close the
door I said sure and he says do you
might have asked you a personal question
I said no I don't mind the taursus
you're a Christian and you preach I said
yes and he said to me I want to be a
Christian but I can't and I said why not
he says I'm a lawyer and it's not it's
not reasonable that Christ should die
and pay the price for the sinner because
if I'm in a court of law and there is a
guilty person who is a murderer and a
rapist or whatever crime he committed
and somebody else stands up and says I
will die in his place that is an act of
mercy but it's not justice justice
demands that the sinner the guilty party
pay the price so Christianity doesn't
work so I said to him but there's a flaw
in your thinking you see Protestantism
teaches forgiveness and no consequence
and that's what we read in Moody's
writings in the last lecture do you
remember that Protestantism had given up
its moral compass and had not allowed
the Bible to teach them that it's not
enough to have Jesus as your Savior you
must be fully obedient you must come
back into harmony with obedience
so I said you are right except for one
thing that the Bible clearly teaches
that if you are in Christ you must die
in Christ so I die in Christ and I am
resurrected in Christ so it requires a
new birth
it requires the death of the old man and
the resurrection of the new man who will
allow God to work in his life so who
pays the price
Jesus pays the price cooperatively for
all of humanity because he had humanity
in him but I have to pay the price too
I have to die and once I have accepted
Jesus as my savior I must die to self
and I must be resurrected in him that is
the new birth and without it I cannot
see heaven I am a new man my own mother
doesn't recognize me from what I was
before if I was a drunkard I'm sober if
I was a glutton I'm no longer a glutton
etc they must be a change if I lived in
disharmony with God's requirements I
must now live in harmony with God's
requirements so Christianity without
consequence is not true Christianity so
the wrath of God descended on his son he
paid the price for me corporative Lee as
the corporate man the god man the only
one who was fully human and yet fully
divine and that requires that I have to
come back into harmony with his law and
the rectitude of his government
he's my king as well so is the
cornerstone of Christian doctrine romans
5 for when we were yet without strength
in due time Christ died for the ungodly
for scarcely for a righteous man will
one die yet peradventure
for a good man some would even dare to
die but God commendeth his love towards
us in that while we were yet sinners
Christ died for us it is clear in
Scripture that Jesus Christ died for us
much more than being justified by his
blood that means by his death we shall
be saved from wrath through him so he's
the one who took the wrath of God this
is what the scripture teaches for if
when we were enemies we were reconciled
to God by the death of his son is the
scripture clear on urges much more being
reconciled we shall be saved by his life
and not only so but we also joined God
through our Lord Jesus Christ by whom we
have now received the atonement the at
one month we are one with God again we
paid the price for me he being divine
and all humanity being in him he paid
the price he died not only for me he
died as me and he died as you he died
for everyone he paid the price the wages
of sin is death and because he had no
sin as a humans no sin he rose from the
dead and divinity took humanity with it
and rose from the dead and now by
accepting by faith his sacrifice on my
behalf and repenting and allowing the
old man to die in him I can have eternal
life being resurrected in him it is no
longer I but live but Christ who lives
in me
it's a beautiful doctrine it is a
logical doctrine it satisfies the
requirements of justice and it satisfies
the requirements of mercy beautiful yes
now the Roman Catholic view of the
atonement
at the Council of Trent the Declaration
of which are still in force the Roman
Catholic Church formally condemned the
biblical doctrine of faith alone
consider the following if anyone says
that justified faith is nothing else
than confidence in divine mercy which we
met sense for Christ's sake or that it
is the confidence alone this confidence
alone that justifies us let in being an
asthma letting be cursed
the Bible says you are saved by faith
alone they curse you if anyone says that
the justice received is not preserved
and also not increased before God
through good works but that those works
are merely the fruits and the signs of
justification obtained but not the cause
of its increase let him be in an admiral
is this biblical no no so are they an
institution that has the Bible as its
source
no no they denied the Bible we just read
the verses nice now let's see whether in
practice this is really so so what are
they really saying they're saying that
Jesus never died for you he died as an
act of perfect obedience but not for you
you still have to pay the price for your
own sins so what was he was just a nice
example so we can also be like that if
we can do it by our own works right then
we become Christ that's new age teaching
Alan John sees the reverent of Grace
Cathedral in San Francisco wrote a book
called reimagining Christianity and in
this he wrote the church's fixation on
the death of Jesus as the universal
saving act must end and the place of the
Cross must be reimagined in Christian
faith why because of the cult of
suffering and the vindictive God behind
it how can God be vindictive
if when he takes upon himself the
penalty that is due to me it is an act
of unbelievable love and I say it is
vindictive so this really means that
they have an image of God the wrathful
father and the separate being the son
who has to bear the wrath because the
father is not willing to bear it exactly
but there's one God and Jesus being
fully God and one with the father
the godhood was involved in that cross
sacrifice in its totality because so far
as to say of the atonement Jones also
says Jesus the sacrifice was to appease
an angry god you can only say something
like that if you don't believe that
Jesus was fully God or that he perhaps
only had an imputed godhood he was fully
man and he was fully God he was
according to the scripture that creator
God he's the one who spoke in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God he's the
one who spoke humanity into existence
without him was not anything created so
we believe in a personal God a personal
God through whom we have access to Jesus
Christ who is a person but one with the
father so penal substitution was the
name of what he calls this vile doctrine
so the fact that the Bible teaches that
God took upon himself in Jesus Christ
the penalty for my sin is a vile doctor
the Bible calls it the gospel which
means good news
and they call it vile news this is a
serious issue here's another one
Richard Lenin is a certainly based
Jesuit priest who is also the director
of the Australian Catholic film office
obviously they like Jesuit theatres
right and he states on the atonement in
an Aradia interview most of the radio
interviewed titled what to say to
suffering and death was interesting but
I found Richards comments on atonement
particularly so in the top ten teams of
four Christians right throughout the
world I think how great thou art gets
into the top five almost every time and
indeed I love how great thou art we sang
it at mass only just recently and I gave
it out with gusto with great gusto but I
can't sing verse three I wonder through
Glades in verse one and I shout with
acclamation in verse five but verse
three says and when I think that God his
son not sparing sent him to die I scarce
can take it in what a beautiful verse
well I can scarce take it in two because
I don't believe that sort of theology it
comes at a particular moment in Catholic
theology called atonement theory it's
not a theory from the 11th century and
is based on Paul's letter to the Romans
so it's got some New Testament roots
just look how they brush aside Scripture
but when you unpack those parts in the
New Testament they are used in a very
particular way that I think have lost
their meaning now about buying back
slaves and the whole process of
redemption and then it gets picked up
about the tournament and then the
Protestant reformers really perfected in
what is called satisfaction theology
that's the only way for God to get happy
with the world was the perfect son to
make the perfect sacrifice so God's
anger would be satisfied no
but justice the wages of sin is days the
only way to solve the problem to be
still a just God is to bear the penalty
himself how can they distort this in
this fashion there's another way that
you can get into why Jesus died and that
is why was Jesus killed see it didn't
die for you and I say in the book that
maybe it's just more helpful now to say
that Jesus didn't come primarily to die
it came to live but what does the Bible
say in whom we have redemption through
his blood even the forgiveness of sins
Colossians 1:14 Jesus died for me right
Colossians 1:20 and having made peace
through the blood of his cross by him to
reconcile all things unto himself by him
I say whether they be things on earth or
things in heaven and you that was
sometimes alienated and enemies in your
mind by wicked works yet now has he
reconciled in the body of his flesh
through death to present you holy and
unblameable and Unruh provable in his
sight through his righteousness and
almost all things says Hebrews 9:22
or by the law by the law purged with
blood and without the shedding of blood
no remission is the Bible clearness so
anybody who believes that Jesus didn't
die for you on the cross that includes
the Islam they denied the atonement that
includes Mormonism Mormonism denies the
atonement that's rather sad this is the
essence of Christianity there's a
beautiful hymn that was penned by
Charles Wesley and the same is
considered one of the best-loved of
Wesley's 6,000 hymns and it's called and
can it be it's one of my favorites
unlike the Jesuit I can sing it with
full gusto
I love this the Sun and can it be that I
should gain an interest in the Savior's
blood dydy for me who caused his pain
for me who him to death pursued amazing
love how can it be that now my God
should die for me
he understood it and then the refrain
must be very icky to the Jesuits amazing
love how can it be that thou my god
should die for me the most beautiful
Christian doctrine this mystery all the
mortal dies who can explore a strange
design in vain the first-born serif
tries to sound the depth of love divine
tis mercy all letter that all let angel
Minds inquire no more amazing love how
can it be that thou my gods should die
for me
he left his Father's throne above so
free so infinities grace emptied himself
of all but loved and bled for Adams
helpless race tis mercy all he mentioned
free for oh my god it found out me isn't
it beautiful beautiful amazing love how
can it be that thou my god should stifle
me by removing the atonement you remove
the centrality of Christ and you put
your manatee in its place you get there
by your works you pay your own price
even your forgiving sins you pay for in
purgatory and Jesus is removed out of
the equation then what was his purpose
nice examples that's all that's all just
a nice example we must be careful that
we make Jesus just our example he is our
example yes but he is much more than our
example
he is our God link is our king he is our
Savior he is our atonement he is the
Lamb of God that taketh away the sins of
the world anything less than that is
paganism is Babylonian religion can you
see why we must flee out of Babylon long
my imprisoned spirit life was bound in
sin and nature's nighttime I diffused
the quickening ray I woke the dungeon
flamed with life my chains fell off my
heart was free I rose went forth and
followed the amazing love how can it be
that thou my god should Steiff or me and
endless beautiful verse no condemnation
now I tread Jesus and all in him is mine
alive in him my living head and clothed
in righteousness divine bold I approach
the eternal throne and claim the crown
through Christ my own and then the verse
amazing love how can it be that thou my
God's should die for me Wesley
understood the core of Christianity a
final false
Sunday observance this is the apostolic
letter D s domine of the Holy Father
John Paul the second to the bishops and
the clergy when through the centuries
she had made laws concerning Sunday rest
and remember this is the very shrine
that Donald Trump went to is and when
they knelt at the shrine of John Paul
Wester of John Paul the second went
through the centuries she has made laws
concerning Sunday rest the church has
had in mind above all the work of
servants and workers certainly not
because this work was any less worthy
when compared to the spiritual
requirements of Sunday observance but
rather because it needed
regulation to lighten its burden and
thus enable everyone to keep the Lord's
Day holy in this matter my predecessor
Pope Leo in his encyclical rerum Novarum
spoke of Sunday rest as the workers
right which the state must guarantee
therefore also at the particular
circumstances of our time Christians
will naturally strive to ensure that
civil legislation respects their duty to
keep Sunday only he wants church and
state to be together isn't that what the
Bible says will happen yep is an
interesting catechism this is the
Catechism explained Bella mean forum now
Bella mean is of course Cardinal Bella
mean yes and it's interesting that the
Protestant world today believes Cardinal
Bella means version of the Antichrist
and you know the future Antichrist that
is to come yes
so is that Babylonian law is that
biblical nice Babylonian okay now this
the six commandments of Rome
particularly pertain to the Sunday so
they're rather interesting the six
precepts of the church on amplification
of the third commandment of the
Decalogue now of course actually that's
the fourth commandment because because
ROM removed the second commandment then
I only had nine Commandments so they
divided the tenth one into two to get
Ten Commandments but everything moved up
one so the third is really the fourth so
they don't work according to the Bible
at all they work according to their
tradition yes the six precepts of the
church on amplification of the third
commandment which is actually the fourth
so it's the satiric movement the first
precept of the church enjoins upon the
faithful to rest from work on certain
days besides the
one day to give thanks to God for
special graces the second precept of the
church ordains the manner in which
sunday and other holy days of obligation
are to be observed and the third and
fourth precepts of the church obliged us
to confess and communicate at least once
a year
the first precept puts us to support our
pastors and the sixth forbids us to
marry non Catholics or to solemnize
marriage as forbidden times at forbidden
times okay so they've got all kinds of
rules which are not biblical they're
based on tradition and the Bible says in
vain they worship Me for doctrines of
men correct teaching their traditions as
doctrine so these are particular laws
it's interesting that on one of the
conservative Catholic sites that they
claim that even Donald Trump is not
legally married to his wife because he
is a Protestant and unless he gets that
annulled and then married again under
Catholic conditions then only will he be
truly married in the eyes of the church
so that's an interesting point so number
two we are under a rigorous obligation
to keep the commandments of the church
for their disobedience to the church is
disobedience to Christ but which Christ
not the Christ of the Bible because he
told us to keep the seventh day and they
telling us to keep the first day so this
must be the other Christ on earth right
Christ has conferred upon the church the
same powers which he himself received
from his father he said to his apostles
as the father has sent me I said you
there's a difference between sending
someone and obeying totally new precepts
right yes
he never said as the father sent me with
laws and Commandments to teach you I
said you to teach you our laws and
Commandments he never said that
so when the church enjoins
anything upon us it is the same as if
Christ had joined it even if it's
contrary to his word for I said
whatsoever you shall bind upon earth
shall be bound also in heaven in
disobeying the church we disobey Christ
as he told there Postel he that despises
you despises me the Lord speaks of the
church as a kingdom he also compares it
to a fault to teach us that the children
of the church must obey the
ecclesiastical superiors every society
is authorized to make laws which the
members must observe this the church
doesn't by her mouth God makes his
well-known to us he therefore wanton Lee
violates one of the church's laws
commits a grievous sin it's interesting
that the spirit of prophecy tells us let
no man tell you your duty we can be in
harmony around the scripture but I may
not be your conscience and you may not
be my conscience my conscience must be
dictated to by God yes three the rulers
of the church are empowered to dispense
the faithful from observance of any of
the commandments of the church for
weighty reasons that's very interesting
does God say under certain circumstances
you don't have to keep my Commandments
no has he never said that no way in this
group to arrive under circumstances
you're not you don't have to keep the
commandments certainly not there's
nothing like that in the Bible in fact
he said those who love me keep my
Commandments and I changed nighttime the
Lord I changed not but Rob says that
they can set aside the commandments the
first commandment of the church the
observance of Sunday and holy days
that's the first commandment the most
important in the first commandment of
the church the solemn observance of holy
days is enjoined upon us there are seven
festivals of our Lord
five of our Lady and three of the
it's very interesting so in Catholic
Christian instructed through have this
question has the Catholic Church power
to make any alterations in the
commandments of God answer instead of
the seventh day and other festivals
appointed by the old law the church has
prescribed the Sunday and holy days to
be set apart for God's worship and these
we are now obliged to keep in
consequence of God's commandments
instead of the ancient Sabbath so who
changed it Roman Catholicism by whose
authority the church their own
authorities only for authority now here
is a document from June the 17th 2020 so
this is very new and it is crisis
magazine a voice for the faithful
Catholic laity and it says print black
back the blue laws so in the United
States on the seventh day of the week
Trade and Industry seems suspended
throughout the nation all noise ceases a
deep peace or rather a sort of solemn
contemplation takes its place the soul
regains its own domain and devotes
itself to meditation Alex the
Tocqueville wrote these words in his
1835 masterpiece of political and social
analysis democracy in America so that's
an old statement and then it talks about
this beautiful piece that they had when
they kept Sunday we dropped down it says
here nevertheless Americans in those
early quarantine days talking about
covered 19 after the haze of their
Netflix binge had evaporated woke up
with a surprised appreciation for what
earlier generations had considered
normal Sunday laws otherwise known as
blue laws as America returns to
normality we
should consider these laws and their
many fold benefit afresh should get them
back acknowledging the rewards of the
Sabbath are not limited only to
Christians like Pope Francis who in a
2018 interview declared one day of the
week that's the least out of gratitude
to worship God to spend time with family
to play to do all those things we are
not machines
they then quote here say Lefkowitz a
lawyer a Jewish lawyer who said that the
Jews also kept the Sabbath and it brings
a healthy separation and balance between
work and play and worship and all of
these things and then it refers back to
that earlier quote more seriously this
individual identified several benefits
to the ones common American inclination
to rest the first thing is how to
worship how the worship of God Orient's
man towards transcendence and its
purposes at church the american hairs of
the need to control his desires of the
subtle pleasures of virtue alone true
happiness they bring and then he sings a
eulogy about how wonderful it was when
they all kept the sunday the second
benefit is the tempering quality of
sabbath observance on an american
capitalism that can tend towards
exclusively materialistic ends that
obscure man's inherent dignity this is
talking like the papacy where they were
to control the economy and sunday and is
part of this law dr. C is very plain on
this issue the top-loading carries on
and he perceived that democratic
capitalism if untethered from religion
would devolve into dehumanizing
materialistic wasteland where men
callate and exploit one another for
profitable game so you have this whole
social doctrine coming in there third in
directing citizens towards transcendent
and Sabbath laws inspire men to pursue
societal goods that will endure beyond
their own circumscribed lives in
skeptical times therefore there's always
the danger that men will surrender
themselves endlessly to the casual whims
of daily desire so what we really need
is this noble calm that comes upon us
when we keep these days where the soul
finds momentarily voids of belief and
the love of physical pleasure spreads to
fill it entirely if you don't keep the
Sabbath now with the few and novelists
holed out Sunday's are more or less
indistinguishable from other days some
counties still pray but the sale of
alcohol and Sunday some Florida counties
bribe at the sale of sex toys on Sunday
amongst other curiosities horse racing
and car dealerships are closed in
Illinois many European nations never
abandoned Sunday trading restrictions
and the economies have managed just fine
so what are they suggesting Sunday
keeping Sunday rest America for the sake
of its own emotional and spiritual
welfare for the sake of your own sanity
needs to restore the blue laws is there
a movement to get the sunday back 100%
they are talking about reset we must
make a what's up about recent yes they
want to reset everything they want to
reset society that want to reset the
economy they want to reset the industry
they want to
said the environment they went to reset
the social order anything has to be
reset reset a new world a new post
Korona world absolutely and they will be
a place for Sunday legislation in the
state of pushing it and interesting this
talks against capitalism so the way you
started in the previous like discussion
that we had this is clashing with Trump
we have this interesting clash so now in
contrast to what we've just read Malachi
3 says 5 the Lord I changed not
therefore ye sons of Jacob are not
consumed the Lord does not change his
nature has not changed and his law has
not changed do not think that I have
come to abolish the law says Jesus James
1:17 every good gift and every perfect
gift is from above and cometh down from
the Father of lights with whom is no
variableness neither shadow of turning
you cannot just change God's law
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall you labor and do all your
work we know the Sabbath commandment how
long for all eternity I am the Lord I
changed not so he blessed the Sabbath
day and he hallowed it
Deuteronomy says and thou shalt remember
all the ways which the LORD thy God led
thee these forty years in the wilderness
to Humble the improve thee to know what
was in thine heart whether that would
keep his Commandments or not nowhere is
there permission to change God's
commandments therefore thou shalt keep
the commandments of the LORD thy God to
walk in his way and to fear him beware
that thou forget not the LORD thy God in
not keeping his Commandments and his
judgments and statutes which I command
thee Thursday whose authority shall we
acknowledge God's Authority he said the
choice of worship
so if you choose to obey the papacy with
regard to the Sunday rather than the
Bible then you are choosing the
authority of another deity on this earth
the doctrine of the serpent
correct Deuteronomy 10:13 says to keep
the commandments of the Lord's and his
statutes which I command you this day
for thy good therefore thou shalt love
the Lord thy God and keep his charge and
his statutes and his judgments and his
Commandments always God does not change
therefore shall you keep the
commandments which I command you this
day that you be strong and go and
possess the land whether you go to
possess it blessing if you obey the
commandments of God which I command you
and a curse if you are paying not the
commandments of the Lord in the Bible is
very clear
Deuteronomy 26 18 and the Lord has a
varsity Thursday to be a peculiar people
as he has promised thee and that thou
should keeps all his Commandments he
says in Deuteronomy 28 13 and the Lord
shall make thee the head not to tell and
thou shalt be above only and thou shalt
not be beneath if thou hearken unto the
commandments of the LORD thy God which I
command thee this day to observe and to
do them if Protestantism had kept the
commandments they would never have been
sucked into the ecumenical movement to
obey the precepts of the Pope they
wouldn't have become become part of
Babylon in Psalms 112 we read praise ye
the Lord blessed is the man that fear us
the Lord that delighteth greatly in his
Commandments there shall I not be
ashamed when I have respect unto all thy
Commandments with my whole heart I have
sought thee oh let me not wander from my
Commandments I mean the Bible is replete
John 14 if you love me keep my
Commandments
14:21 he that has my Commandments and
keepeth amis the one that loveth me 15
verse 10 if you keep
my Commandments you abide in my love I
mean Old Testament New Testament no
difference Paul actually says
circumcision is nothing and
uncircumcision in nothing but keeping
the commandments of God that's what's
important not the rituals and the other
things and hereby we know that we know
him if we keep his Commandments it is so
clear and he that says I marry and keeps
not his Commandments is a liar and they
believe the doctrine of the serpent by
this we know that we love the children
of God when we love God and keep his
Commandments for this is the love of God
that we keep his Commandments and His
commandments are not Grievous I mean I
could carry on it verse after verse
tuesday/thursday says Joshua whom you
shall serve in Revelation also says in
revelation 22 verse 14 blessed are they
that keep the commandments that they may
access to the tree of life so here's the
bottom line when we look at this issue
of obedience to God has God really said
and this issue of do we keep the
precepts of God or do we keep the
precepts of the world do we believe the
serpent or do we believe God that is the
choice any organization that follows the
lead of the beast becomes part of
Babylon and when Protestantism has given
up the biblical precepts in favor of the
Roman precepts then it has fallen yes
and become part of Babylon so that is
why the message is repeated a second
time Babylon is fallen is fallen because
there has been another component at
added it was always the dragon it was
always the beast but unfortunately it is
now also the false prophet come out of
her my people that you be not partakers
of her sins and this is what the Bible
teaches
and we have a choice we can either
follow the Bible and make that the rule
of faith or we can follow in the
footsteps of the world and in the
spiritual exercises and become swallowed
up in spiritualistic teachings as for me
in my house and I would invite you to to
follow the Lord thus says the Lord will
you pray for us I will however father
thank you so much for giving us such
clear in the teachings in your word help
us to implement into our lives and bless
the people that watch this and also us
and bring us again together Jesus name
Amen
amen thank you for watching this video
to subscribe click here when the bell
appears click again to get notifications
to watch the next video click here thank
you